[موسيقى]
هذه أخبار عاجلة ،
مرحبًا بكم في الصدارة ، أنا
أتعامل مع الأخبار العاجلة ،
أي مواطن أمريكي يعتقد أن
أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الجمهوريين
ربما وصلوا أخيرًا إلى حدودهم
مع دونالد ترامب بعد أن حرض السيد ترامب
على هجوم إرهابي على مبنى الكابيتول الأمريكي.
في خمس حالات وفاة بما في ذلك
ضابط شرطة العاصمة
حسنًا ، لدي أخبار سيئة بالنسبة لك ،
يبدو أنهم لم
يمضوا وقتًا قصيرًا على أداء اليمين لأعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
من أجل المحاكمة الثانية لعزل
الرئيس السابق لأعضاء مجلس الشيوخ الذين
رفعوا أيديهم اليمنى
وأقسموا اليمين على أن يكونوا محلفين محايدين
يصطفون للتوقيع
على كتاب القسم لأنهم يعتبرون
المادة الوحيدة للمساءلة التي
تتهم السيد ترامب بالتحريض على
التمرد في العاصمة الأمريكية
، ومن المقرر أن تبدأ المحاكمة أسبوعين
من اليوم في 9 فبراير
بعد لحظات من أداء جميع أعضاء مجلس الشيوخ
اليمين الدستورية السناتور الجمهوري راند
أثار بول من كنتاكي نقطة نظام
للتساؤل عما إذا كان من غير
الدستوري محاكمة رئيس مجلس الشيوخ السابق مي
صوت زعيم نورتي ميتش ماكونيل لصالح
اقتراح بول على
الرغم من أنها فشلت في النهاية مع خمسة
جمهوريين فقط
انضم خمسة ديمقراطيين للمضي قدمًا
في المحاكمة ، لذا كان التصويت 55 لصالح
المضي قدمًا في المحاكمة
45 بعد أن قال إنها غير دستورية الآن
أبحاث الكونغرس غير الحزبية
تقول الخدمة أن الاقتباس من
معظم العلماء الذين فحصوا السؤال عن كثب
قد خلصوا إلى أن
الكونجرس
لديه سلطة لتوسيع عملية الإقالة
لتشمل المسؤولين الذين لم يعودوا
في مناصبهم
، وبينما من المؤكد أن بعض هذه الأصوات الـ 45
قد تكون مبنية على قانون دستوري مختلف ،
فلنكن  بعيون واضحة بشأن
السياسة السارية هنا وما تنبأ به تصويت اليوم
لإدانة الديمقراطيين دونالد ترامب
ستحتاج لكسب أكثر من 17
جمهوريًا راند بول يقول إن تصويت اليوم
أظهر أن
الإدانة ماتت عند الوصول